[Music]  whatever happened to you  you have gifts now everything breaks  victor i can't wait to see what you can  feed him on  these boxes will get inside you and find  your weaknesses in your fears  take your place among the brave ones  i'm not broken and i'm not alone  [Music]  the bells didn't rub  out in the dark  among the stars the god is dead  [Applause]  i had a dream  almost like a premonition  i think there's an attack coming  this wall will fall  [Music]  i need warriors i'm building an alliance  to defend ourselves  how do you know your team's strong  enough if you can't bring down the  charging bull  then don't wave the red cape at it  you're sitting here for a reason  and even if it takes you the rest of  your life  find out what that reason is  said the age of heroes would never come  again  it will it has to  [Music]  we live in a society where honor  is a distant memory isn't that right  batman  [Music]  you